[Applause]
[Music]
ukraine is the elephant in the room of
europe think about it
europe is the most peaceful continent on
the planet except for ukraine this
country has been invaded by russia for
six
years and the question is what is nato
doing about it
in previous visualpolitik videos we've
already told you why ukraine is the
poorest country in europe and yes it is
true
the main factor to explain all this
mystery is the corruption of the
ukrainian elites themselves however it
is
undeniable that the russian invasion
makes it very difficult for ukraine to
pull itself out of this poverty take a
look at this map
[Music]
since 2014 the crimean peninsula has
been directly controlled by russia in
addition these two easternmost regions
which are called donetsk and lehansk
are controlled by separatists who in
turn are supported by russia at any
moment
russia could try to conquer more regions
so the question is would you set up a
factory
or an office in ukraine knowing that at
any moment the city you are in could go
to war and you'll say
come on do you really think that russia
could invade more regions of ukraine and
the answer is
why wouldn't they think of it this way
the war between ukraine and russia is
totally imbalanced ukraine spends about
5.2 billion
a year on its armed forces russia spends
65 billion and that explains why new
stories like this one are so concerning
ukraine says russia still has 100 000
troops near its borders al jazeera
11th of may 2021 for the time being
russia has not advanced its positions
at least not since 2014 but if one day
they did
what could ukraine do how could they
defend themselves as you can imagine the
situation in this country is critical
and that explains why the ukrainian's
number one wish
is this ukraine wants to speed up
joining nato to send
a real signal to russia euro news the
6th of april 2021.
so why is it so important for ukraine to
join nato you may ask in case some of
you don't know
nato is a defense union that is if you
attack a member country the rest are
obliged to retaliate
in other words if ukraine were a nato
member country the united states
germany france and spain would have to
send troops to defend them they would no
longer be alone against the russian
empire so the question is
is it possible for ukraine to join nato
and is nato really ready to accept them
and more importantly
how are ukraine's armed forces preparing
to defend themselves against russia
today we're going to answer these
questions but first
let's take a look at a bit of history
and kalashnikovs they say a picture is
worth a thousand words
so i'm gonna show you a video in order
for you to understand how the ukrainian
army
operated up until the 2014 war what i'm
going to show you now is real it is an
official recruitment announcement for
joining the ukrainian armed forces let's
take a look at it because it's
absolutely priceless
well here we see some sort of ukrainian
yokel trying to pick up some chicks by
showing off his brand new bmw
something that's obviously pretty
typical in ukraine
but suddenly something unexpected
happens a tank appears
also pretty normal in ukraine apparently
and in that tank there are three
soldiers with so much makeup on that
they look like barbie's boyfriend ken
and here the soldier called dmitry
climbs down and asks the girls for some
water and of course
the girls pass on the yokel you know
guys if you want to pull chicks in
ukraine a tank is better than a bmw and
here it is when they share with you the
ultimate reason for enlisting in the
ukrainian army
check it out
there you have it in any other country
enrollment ads appeal to patriotism
sacrifice or military values
ukrainians wanted citizens to sign up
for the army because its soldiers get to
spend all night long showing off the
girls in their shiny tank and partying
remember this ad is real and it was paid
for by the ukrainian government so this
means that this was the impression
ukraine had of its own army the ad keeps
going
now they talk for a while i work in the
army i want to marry you do you have an
insta and then the soldiers leave
[Music]
ukrainian army why choose between making
love or making war
and you can have both well after seeing
this masterpiece i'm going to give you
some data that will leave you terrified
ukraine
is one of the largest arms exporters in
the world
that's right during the soviet era
ukraine produced 30 percent of the
ussr's armaments there were more than 1
million people
working in the more than 750 ukrainian
arms factories
and you will say so what happened after
the fall of the soviet union well
something that probably won't surprise
you much almost the entire soviet
arsenal disappeared that's right it is
estimated that between 1992
and 98 ukraine lost more than 32 billion
dollars worth of armaments
so where did all those weapons go well
to wars like sierra leone croatia etc
this was after all the golden age for
illegal arms dealers but the story does
not end there
arms deal is aside the ukrainian state
also did huge business with armaments
all those former soviet factories were
still producing and what were they
producing exactly well mainly
russian weapon parts for example most of
the engines used in russian helicopters
were labelled made in ukraine
to give you an idea in 2012 ukraine was
the fourth largest arms exporter in the
world and its main customers were
pakistan
china and of course russia all this
explains why up until 2014
the majority of ukrainians said no to
joining nato
ukraine says no to nato it is not
surprising that about half of ukrainians
gave nato an unfavorable rating pew
research center 29th of march
2010. and i know what you're thinking so
ukraine is a military power how is it
possible that russia dares to invade
them there are two very important things
that we need to understand
the first is that ukraine only exported
parts for manufacturing weapons
in other words ukraine was barely
capable of producing any specific weapon
but that's not all as you can imagine
the ukrainian military industry was no
stranger to corruption to give you an
idea
in 2010 all armed companies were unified
under one conglomerate
you cropper romprom
this company employs more than 80 000
people however in 10 years they have
barely managed to manufacture one single
tank in its entirety
as usual in this country almost all the
money for armaments ended up in the
pockets of oligarchs and politicians
so what about the army well looking at
the video i showed you earlier you can
already get an idea
in 2014 ukraine had 168 000 soldiers the
territorial army had 41 000 troops
for example but of those 41 000 troops
only 6 000 were ready to fight and when
i say ready to fight
i mean that they were trained and
equipped that is only 6 000 soldiers had
such basic things as boots camouflage
suits and rifles given this situation
you will understand
why the russian invasion was a military
walkover and the question that you may
be wondering now is how can ukraine
defend itself today have they changed
their army or are they just going to
surrender sooner or later well we're
going to take a look at that right now
a crowdfunded army in case anybody is a
bit lost in this story
let's recap in 2013
thousands of ukrainians took to the
streets in protest and overthrew the
government which was pro-russian in 2014
ukraine appointed a new government that
was anti-russian this provoked the
russian-speaking regions of ukraine to
want to secede from the country russia
invaded the crimean peninsula and
supported the separatist rebels of the
donbass region
i know this is a very broad summary but
if you want it in more detail we have
several videos where we cover this
conflict in depth as i mentioned earlier
ukraine had hardly any soldiers to fight
on the front lines
well thousands of civilians went to war
of their own volition
[Music]
that's right ordinary citizens with no
training no weapons
no equipment whatsoever got in their
cars and went to the front to
fight that's how the volunteer
battalions were born
[Music]
within these battalions there were
people of all types and ideologies
if you follow russian propaganda
channels you already know that many of
them were neo-nazi groups but alongside
them there were also muslim groups
and you're probably thinking muslims in
ukraine yes
there were for example the sheikh mansur
battalion were warriors who came from
chechnya to support the cause and you
may ask
but what is the use of having so many
warriors if they don't even have
weapons remember that these volunteers
could be any one of you can you imagine
that
suddenly you find yourself fighting on
the front line how do you get a rifle
who pays for it well take a look
crowdfunding a war in a david versus
goliath-like battle ukrainian forces
look to private companies and
crowdfunded volunteer organizations to
develop defense software and drone
hardware in their fight against russia
the guardian the 24th of may 2015.
that's right
faced with the vacuum left by the
official army ukrainians organized
themselves in their own way this is how
ngos like come back alive emerged buying
bulletproof vests and night vision
goggles for volunteer soldiers
[Music]
this ngo alone raised more than one
hundred thousand dollars in its first 45
days of existence
so where do they get so much money in a
country as poor as ukraine well the
answer is from the ukrainian diaspora
there are more than 20 million
ukrainians scattered around the world
around 345 000 of them live in the
united states and have enough money to
make donations
so in a very short time volunteer armies
raised millions of dollars to buy guns
boots and all kinds of military
equipment and you will say what a nice
story
right an army created by the people
actually there is another uglier name
for this practice
we're actually talking about illegal
arms trafficking and that explains news
stories like this
paypal doesn't work in ukraine but
resourceful locals
know how to use it the kiev post 5th of
october 2018.
we're not just talking about paypal one
of the conditions set by the us for
sending weapons to ukraine was that all
those volunteer groups would join the
regular army
in fact by 2019 almost all of those
volunteers were already regular soldiers
and this is where the good news finally
comes in because these volunteer forces
are much more motivated and harder to
corrupt
remember that in 2014 ukraine barely had
any combat ready soldiers well
right now we're talking about 250 000
troops they don't have particularly good
weaponry but
at least they all have boots suits and
rifles ukraine's army has
changed from the bottom up but it's
better if you take a look for yourselves
check out the new advertisement for
recruiting soldiers
yes
i think it speaks for itself in any case
the question you may be asking
yourselves is
is all this enough to defend ukraine
against a russian attack
or is nato assistance still necessary
well we're going to look at that right
now
could ukraine join nato the short answer
to this question
no i mean nobody can predict the future
at visualpolitik we don't have a crystal
ball but
it is very difficult to imagine ukraine
joining nato for one very simple reason
if ukraine joins nato
russia would have its enemy on the
border this would be reason enough for
russia to go to open war to avoid it in
other words it is very risky and as sad
as it sounds for the ukrainians watching
this video the reward does not outweigh
the risk
we could say that this thinking is what
has guided the us and eu stance in
recent years
and you will say so no one is willing to
do anything to defend ukraine not
exactly they just want to do it
differently
you see since 2014 the united states has
spent over 2.5 billion dollars in
military aid to ukraine that might sound
like a lot of money but in reality it's
a drop in the bucket
when compared to the more than 6.4
trillion dollars that has been spent on
wars in the middle east
in any case this money has been enough
to send an arsenal that has been key for
avoiding casualties for example
ukraine has now more than 300 humvees
which are those armored all-terrain
vehicles that you see in the movies they
have also sent anti-artillery radars
with this equipment alone ukraine is
estimated to have reduced casualties by
70 percent
[Music]
nato has also sent thousands of
instructors to train the soldiers and
you will say
that's all couldn't they have just sent
them some artillery and rifles at the
end of the day both radars and humvees
are useless for attacking we're talking
about a war
so where are the lethal weapons and this
is where we come back to what i
mentioned before
nato wants to avoid attacks at all costs
the goal is to prevent the situation
from escalating and you could see that
very well with this example
ukraine gets u.s military aid including
javelin anti-tank missiles
reuters 17th of june 2020. have you ever
played call of duty if so you're
probably familiar with the javelin
rocket launcher
it's a portable rocket launcher system
that is that you carry on your shoulders
and you fire projectiles that destroy
tanks
now that's a lethal weapon and it's not
just any weapon to give you an idea each
of the units cost
280 thousand dollars but that's just the
cannon
each rocket costs 174 000
in other words for the same cost as a
single javelin shot you could buy an
apartment in almost any city in the
world
[Music]
as you can imagine these rocket
launchers would be crucial in a battle
against russian tanks but there's a
catch ukraine can't have its 37 brand
new javelins on the front line that's
right
they are forced to store them in a depot
in the western regions of the country
hundreds of kilometers away from
the war zone
and why you may ask what is the point of
sending weapons to the country and not
letting them use them there is a
one-word answer deterrence neither the
united states
nor nato wants ukraine to attack russia
nor do they want to arouse putin's fury
so they limit themselves to enough
weaponry to deter russia from escalating
the war in other words it is very
difficult to think that ukraine would
ever join nato however
nato is helping ukraine to modernize its
military so that it can withstand
further attacks
[Music]
but now the question is over to you do
you think that this is enough will we
see new attacks from russia again is it
just a matter of time before nato has to
enter fully into this conflict do you
think
ukraine can really modernize its
military or is it going to be impossible
to stamp out corruption you can leave me
your answers in the comments and as
always
don't forget that here on visualpolitik
we release new videos every week so
subscribe to this channel
and hit the little bell so you don't
miss any of our updates and if you liked
this video please give it a thumbs up
and i'll be seeing you in the next one
all the best
see you soon